en france toujours nouveau week-end de
contestation plus de quarante mille
personnes ont manifesté hier elles sont
l'ensemble du territoire selon le
ministère de l'intérieur qui passe
sanitaire mais surtout gilet jaune dans
les ruelles approche du troisième
anniversaire du mouvement ils se
mobilisent notamment contre la hausse
des prix d'énergie un nouveau souffle
qui fait craindre au gouvernement
la résurgence d'une crise sociale
d'ampleur à la proche de l'élection
présidentielle et m masculin
le retour de gilet jaune et bien actée
ce samedi encore ils étaient plusieurs
centaines à défiler dans les rues de
paris un nouveau souffle porté par la
protestation contre la hausse des prix
du carburant un combat qu'il mène depuis
2018 et qui avait été à la base de leur
mouvement dans la capitale
un défilé dans le calme mais une colère
toujours bien présent
qu'ils arrêtent de nous taxer qu'ils
arrêtent de se gaver sur des produits de
première nécessité indispensable pour
l'ensemble des français on ouvre
inquiétant en nous prenons toujours
notre argent et on se demande en
derrière comment on pourrait faire pour
leur permettre de diminuer un petit peu
lent charge en leur versant notre argent
alors c'est un comble après une chute
des prix de l'énergie en 2020 ces tarifs
connaissent un fort rebond depuis l'été
pour étouffer la colère qui couve
le gouvernement a décidé de sortir son
chéquier
nous allons décider d'une sorte d'
indemnité inflation de 100 euros qui
sera versée aux français qui gagnent
moins de 2000 euros net par mois une
aide qui concernerait près de 38
millions de personnes mais la somme est
jugée dérisoire par de nombreux
protestataires
le chèque de 100 euros c'est juste pour
endormir les gens parce que si vous
divisez 100 euros par part 12 mois ça
fait quoi 8 euros au bout de votre plein
donc c'est pas c'est pas suffisant 100
euros vous retirer les taxes ça veut
dire qu'on à 39 euros sur une année ma
décomptés par jour sauf s'affaisser des
miettes et puis toute façon faut arrêter
de se de notre gueule c'est pas
les 100 euros qui vont changer quoi que
ce soit dans la vie des gens retour aux
sources du mouvement aux abords des
routes point également les gilet jaune
reprennent timidement place dans le
paysage urbain et se mêle désormais aux
antilles passe et autres salariés
suspendu car non vaccinés avec un
message inchangé ou presque j'étais déjà
sur les ronds-points en 2018 et avec les
mêmes revendications a dit on est en
plus grave beaucoup plus grave
aujourd'hui parce que
ça continue en fait ça s'arrête jamais
quoi j'aurais même politique et
donc on est là en 2018 et on sera encore
là un fossé toujours plus large qui
sépare le peuple contestataires du
gouvernement une colère populaire que
redoutent la majorité à six mois de
l'élection présidentielle
le retour des gis les jaunes et
surveiller comme le lait sur le feu par
l'exécutif avec la crainte que le
mouvement reprenne la même ampleur qu il
y a trois ans